And live. Hello Bernie. How are you Joe? Wonderful. Pleasure to meet you.
Nice to meet you. It's exciting to have you here man.
And it's obviously an exciting time for you. Um, you know,
presidential campaign is up in full swing. Do you, do you get frustrated by the,
the time constraints of the debates?
Uh, absolutely. It's, you shouldn't even call them with the beat.
What they are is a, um, you know,
reality TV show in which you have to come up with a sound bite and all that
stuff. It is the meaning,
it's the meaning to the candidates and it's the meaning to the American people.
You can't explain the complexity of healthcare in America in 45 seconds.
Nobody can.
But why is it still done that way if you'd to try to, let's pull this thing
great. Um, you know,
I think the DNC is in a difficult position.
They have 20 plus candidates and they want to give everybody a fair shot,
which is the right thing to do. Uh,
and then if you're gonna have 10 candidates up on the stage, what do you do?
But there are other ways that we've got to do it because the issues facing this
country of someone normous and in some cases so complicated,
nobody in the world can honestly explain them in 45 seconds.
And then that what encourages people to do is to come up with sound to do absurd
things up. I yelled and scream on the show. I took my clothes off. Uh,
it would get a lot of publicity, right?
But if you give a thoughtful answer to a complicated question,
it's not so sexy for the media.
Well, you don't even have a chance to give a thoughtful answer. Let go.
Tulsi Gabbert went after Camilla Harris and then Conwell Harris said about 12
seconds to reply to it. It was so ridiculous to, to,
to have something that's such an important issue. Like did your,
did you not put all those people in jail for marijuana? Did you laugh about it?
Did this happen? Did that happen?
All these different things was evidenced withheld by, that's how they,
these are a long conversation,
but it takes us to another issue and that as a nation we do a pretty bad job in
analyzing and discussing the serious issues facing our country.
And I hold the media to some degree responsible for that. You know,
other countries, what they do is that he, Joe, you want to run for president?
I'll tell you what would the your potty in the general election,
we're going to give you a certain amount of time,
hours on television and you use those hours anyway you want,
you want a 15 minute discussion. You remember Ross Perot? Yes.
And people used to laugh at Ross Perot because he used to get up there with the
chart and all this stuff and, and the media made fun of him,
but in fact he tried in his own weight to explain his point of view to the
American people. And we need serious discussion on, on serious issues.
Well, he had the op, he, because he was so rich,
he had the ability to buy air time on network television,
which is pretty unprecedented.
He just bought a chunk of air time and then pled his case.
But you know what goes on in other countries,
you don't have to by that time what the obligation is. If you are a network,
you're going to make that time free and available to candidates.
Do you think that that's something that could be viable in American? We could.
Could you convince CBS and NBC and ABC to go along with something like that? No,
you couldn't convince them. You'd have to pass legislation to make Lynn hub,
but everyone's online today. The, I mean,
the entire country is essentially getting email and Facebook and all that jazz.
Like why bother doing it in this particular medium that has an inherent time
constraint?
Well, you're right. I mean, the Internet has revolutionized politics,
uh, and in many ways, good ways. We use our social media, our email list,
which is very large.
We every day was sending out stuff and other candidates are doing it the same
way. But television still has a very important role to be playing.
I'm sure it does,
but I mean the ability to discuss things in in long form like you can do online,
like you can do right here, right now. You can't get that on television wide.
You could,
I mean they would have to stay with at an interrupt you every 15 minutes.
No, no, no, no, no.
What I'm saying about is it is in what goes on in other countries,
if I'm not mistaken, like don't hold me to this. I think in the UK,
you're member, the Labor Party, your candidate, here's 30 minutes of time and
do with it as you want. Do you want to speak 30 minutes on healthcare?
Whatever it may be. You can do that. Really? Yeah.
And they don't interrupt with commercial [inaudible]
or that they have given this is the candidates opportunity to speak Atlanta to
the people of the country.
What are, what are the misconceptions of you? Cause here's, here's the,
if you go to the knee jerk conservative reaction,
you talk to people who are not interested in anyone that wants to be a
democratic socialist. They hear the name Bernie Sanders.
The negative implications are that you are somehow or another going to take
their money, right? Does that annoying to you?
Yes it is. Of course it is. And also that line missed the Maduro.
I'm a dictator. I'd love dictatorships and all that stuff.
And the truth is, Joe,
that if you look at the issues that I campaign on and what I believe on,
they are really not terribly radical.
They exist in many countries all over the world. For example,
just we can start on healthcare if you'd like.
Is the idea that healthcare is a human right? Not a privilege, a radical idea.
I don't think it is. It's not. And the truth is,
we are the only major country on earth. Many people don't know this.
We are the only major country on earth not to guarantee healthcare to all people
as a human, right?
And yet we end up spending almost twice as much per capita on healthcare.
The function, and you can argue me with me if you want,
but the function of the current healthcare system is not to provide quality care
to all.
It is to make tens of billions of dollars in profit for the drug companies and
the insurance companies. That's the function.
If you go to Canada and I live 50 miles away from the Canadian border,
you have major heart surgery, you're in the hospital for a month.
Do you know what the bill is when you're going out zero? You got it.
You go to any doctor you want.
You don't have to take out your wallet and yet guarantee your healthcare to all
of their people and they spend one half of what we spend.
That's kind of what I want to do.
And I don't think that that's terribly radical. We have a program now,
which everybody knows it's called Medicare.
It was started by Lyndon Johnson back in 1965. It is a popular program.
Uh,
all that I want to do over a four year period is to expand the today eligibility
age of 65.
I want to take it out of 55 45 35 everybody over four year period.
That's about it.
And I want to expand benefits to include a dental care hearing aids on
eyeglasses as well. That's about it. Not too radical.
Well, that doesn't sound radical at all. No. When you say that they,
that Canada spends less, obviously they have less people,
you mean less per capita? Yes. Half per capita. Exactly.
And the quality of care is as good or better. Do they have problems? Yeah,
they have problems. Everybody has problems,
but overall the healthcare experts will tell you the quality of care there is as
good or better than it is in our country. So what's the hurdle? Okay,
I'll tell you exactly what the hurdle is.
The hurdle is exactly the same thing is in every other aspect of our lives,
it's the power of money. All right. Listen to this.
Over the last 20 years,
the drug companies alone have spent four and a half billion dollars in 20 years
on lobbying and campaign contributions. That's what we're up against,
the knowledge, and I mark my words within a short period of time,
you will see TV ads in California all over this country demonizing Bernie
Sanders. He wants to do this terrible thing to you. He wants to do that.
They have unbelievable amounts of money. Uh,
and politicians are frightened of that power. Give you one example. Uh,
back in 2016 I got involved here in a little way with an effort on the part of
the nurses to control of the cost of prescription drugs in California.
You may recall that effort I do. It was a battle,
an item in one state here in California.
Do you know how much the drug companies alone spent at the feet that epic,
they spent $131 million on one ballot item in one state.
All right? Last year, the top 10 drug companies made $69 billion.
A week ago,
I went to Canada with a number of Americans who are dealing with diabetes.
We bought insulin in Windsor, Ontario for one 10th the price,
10% of the price, same exact product being charged in America.
So you got drug companies that are engaged in collusion and in price fixing who
are incredibly greedy. And the result is many elderly people,
many working people simply cannot afford the medicine they need it. This is,
it's unbelievable.
And the reason for all of that stuff is we are the only country in the world
that does not negotiate with the drug companies.
They can charge you any price they want.
And that has to do with the fact that we don't have a national healthcare
program. Medicare is not negotiating, et cetera.
Is this something that can really be implemented inside of four years?
[inaudible] it's an enormous endeavor.
Well, I want you to think back. Think back Joe. In 65, uh,
you had Linda Johnson as president and Pie.
The way this idea of national healthcare,
this has been talked about literally since Teddy Roosevelt is not a new concept.
Healthcare as human rights is what Teddy Roosevelt was talking about.
That's what FDR was looking about. Harry Truman was talking about it.
Kennedy was talking about it. Kennedy got killed.
Lyndon Johnson picked up the mantle and, and their idea was,
according to people in their administration,
we'll start with the elderly who are most impacted by,
by healthcare costs and sickness. We'll start,
and they did in 1965 without the technology we have today,
they implemented Medicare. 19 million people,
elderly people signed up in the first year.
So if you could slot a brand new program and have 19 million people sign up with
the technology, that is way, way behind where we are today,
why can't we over a four year period, simply expand that program?
I don't think it's such a, a difficult, uh, operation.
So when you talk about the drug companies and the lobbyists and the enormous
amount of money that they spend, is this,
does this exist anywhere else other than the United States lobbyists on that
level? No.
No, of course then, uh, and the reason, you know,
in Canada what you have is you have a national healthcare program and so forth,
and they sit down and a, they negotiate with the drug companies.
They have their own approach.
But every other major country on earth says that the drug companies,
of course you can't charge us any price you want. This is a reasonable price.
Tell me what your profits are, what your expenditures. This is a price for us.
You can walk in, you know, if you have an illness,
you could walk into the pharmacy tomorrow and the price has been doubled and you
say to the pharmacist, what happened? He said, they just raised their prices.
They could do it any day they want, at any price they want.
Now lobbyists are in general, when people talk about lobbyists mean it's a,
it's an unattractive term. We, we think about it in terms of a negative.
We don't, we don't think of, Oh thank God there's lobbyists. We think, wow,
there's someone with enormous amounts of money using that money to gain
influence on politicians and its shapes, regular people.
It shapes our lives mostly in a negative way.
This is the way most people look at it. I'm not saying it's correct. Why?
Why do we have that system in place? Like why do we have lobbyist?
Why is it legal for someone to spend exorbitant amount of money,
exorbitant amounts of money to affect our civilization,
to effect the way our cultural,
I know you're taking us into a whole new area. Yeah. All right, let's look.
Can I, let me detour and I'll come back. I'll do. All right.
Today in America,
you've got three people owning more wealth than the bottom half of the American
society. You don't see that on television too much.
You know you don't three people,
you got the top 1% owning more wealth than the bottom. 92% listen to this,
this is a statistic we recently saw came from the Federal Reserve over the last
30 years.
The top 1% seen a $21 trillion increase in their wealth.
The bottom half of America has seen a $900 billion decline in net wealth.
So what you have in America today is a relatively small number of incredibly
wealthy people, and I deal with these guys everyday.
People are only talking about rich, you don't know what riches,
what multibillion dollar operations are incredible power over our society.
And if you would look pharmaceutical industry and last,
the atten companies made $69 billion in profit.
You're sitting around right now saying, all right, that's great.
How'd we do better next year? What strategy do we have?
Where to pull out of ads on? We're going to work with others.
During the CNN debate that I participated in recently in the debate,
right in the middle of the debate,
the drug companies and the insurance companies had an ad telling how bad
so-called, how bad medicare for all would be. So they,
they're smart guys and they use their power over politicians.
They use their power over the media.
They spend billions of dollars on advertising,
on media to make sure that they make as much as they can in profit.
But it's not any different with Wall Street.
It's not any different than the puzzle fuel industry or the prison industrial
complex. These guys have wealth, they have power,
and they could care less about the needs of working people in this country.
And that's the dynamic of American politics right now. And in our campaign,
look, we've taken them all on and I know it makes a lot of people uncomfortable,
but we are taking on all of these entities and all of their wealth and all of
their power. And that's what a political revolution is about.
So the real problem seems to be that they have this strategy of unlimited
growth,
not that they're not providing medication that people need to save their lives.
I mean, it's obviously important to have pharmaceutical company, of course,
of course. Right? So there's good that they provide,
but the business aspect of it is where the problem lies. Right? Right.
Look, they have great researchers,
but if you check how they even spend their money, you know,
they will tell you the, so all of them wanting got researched about,
we're trying to, we're tackling cancer with tackling diabetes, Alzheimer's,
the truths of costly.
But the bulk of their money is going often to what we call Mitsu drugs.
They make modest changes in a drug which really doesn't improve people's
wellbeing in order to make profits. So the answer is yes,
we need obviously vigorous research and development. And by the way,
your tax dollars,
all of our tax policy often goes to that research and we don't get the benefit
of it in terms of lower
prices. So it's just, it's a business model issue.
It's a greed issue. You've got it.
And how would one stop that when you're dealing with this,
the kind of influence that you're talking about with $69 billion in a year?
I mean the resources they have, how would you stop?
Well, that is kind of what we call the 60 $40 question. Yeah, right.
And I'll tell you what, I think this is what I believe.
If you think back on American history and you think about the real changes that
have taken place in society,
you think about the labor movement and working class people standing up and
saying to their employers, we're not going to be treated like animals anymore.
You can hire and fire as you can't work us, you know, 15 hours a day. We, we,
we deserve dignity. And you think about the growth of the labor movement,
millions of people beginning to stand together and fight.
You think about the civil rights movement, you know,
and it wasn't just Dr. Martin Luther King Jr, it was again,
millions of African Americans in that white allies saying we're going to end
segregation and racism in this country.
You think about the women's movement a hundred years ago,
women in America didn't even have the right to vote.
Think about the gay rights movement. Think about the environmental.
The only way that change takes place is when ordinary people come together and
stand up and fight and say that the status quo is not working.
And that's what I believe and that's what we're trying to do. So with the,
the message of our campaign is it's us, not me,
cause I can't do it alone.
Let me be very honest with you by our elected president tomorrow,
I can't do the things that I would like to do that I'm campaigning on unless
millions of people we're working with me to tell the corporate elite that they
cannot get it all. So how would that be implemented?
Let's say you become president, you've got to become president.
What do you think? I think we're going to shout at it. Guy Shot. All right,
President Bernie. What do you do? You get in there. What do you do? Okay.
First of all, you make a very clear,
you make it clear to the American people what your agenda is.
And I appreciate the opportunity to talk about an agenda and in more than 12
seconds, what does that mean? All right,
we're going to fight for the Medicare for all.
We're going to raise the minimum wage to a living wage.
We are going to deal with education in a profound, profound way.
Cause I worry about what's going on in education today.
Everybody knows that the ages of zero through four are the most important years
for human, intellectual and emotional development, right?
Every psychologist will tell you that.
And yet we have a totally dysfunctional early childhood system. We pay,
we pay out childcare workers, starvation wages,
yet working class families cannot find affordable quality childcare.
You've got to have public school systems all around this country in many of them
really being challenged right now, teaches at run to pay.
Teachers are working two or three jobs.
You've got kids who can't afford to go to college.
And here's something that is just unbelievable. Kids who have gone to college,
leaving school with 50,000, hundred thousand dollars in debt, unbelievable.
These are issues that we have to deal with and I will deal with them. And, uh,
we are gonna substantially improve the quality of education in America.
We're going to cancel student debt by imposing a tax on Wall Street speculation.
All right? So you've gotta deal with education.
You got to deal with climate change. You know,
the truth is that Donald Trump is that wrong. Uh,
climate change is not a hoax. It is a very,
very dangerous reality for our country and the rest of the world.
Scientists tell us we have less than 12 years to transform our energy system
away from fossil fuel or they will be irreparable damage. All right,
so those are in health care of course for all.
So those are some of the major issues. Criminal Justice, immigration reform,
you lay it on the table, you see these,
all the issues that we are going to focus on and you rally the American people
around those issues and you tell people like Mitch McConnell,
who represents a very poor state in Kentucky that Mitch,
if you all going to oppose raising that minimum wage to at least 15 bucks an
hour,
I will be in Kentucky as president of the United States and we're going to have
a rally because you're going to have to stop representing.
And I hope by the way, that Mitch McConnell is not the leader.
I hope the Democrats can gain control over the Senate. But if he is,
we'll put enormous pressure on him to do what the people want. Every idea. Joe,
here's the bottom line. In this thing.
Every idea that I've just talked to you about,
it is supported by a majority of the American people.
These are not radical ideas.
Let's let's take these one step at a time cause you mentioned a lot of important
things there. Let's go with the minimum wage thing.
Now the argument that I've heard about the minimum wage being raised at $15 an
hour is that they're entry level positions for high school kids.
For people that are just getting their feet wet in the marketplace,
they're learning how to work. They're learning,
they're making some money after school that they,
that if you charge or if businesses have to pay $15 an hour to people like that
to entry level people that they won't be able to stay open. Well, first of all,
they will be competing against, you know, if you're a business,
lumber business and both of us have to raise our wages at the same level,
we both have the same burdens. So it's spread across.
That is what my conservative colleagues will tell you. The truth is,
I don't have the numbers right in front of me that while it certainly is true
that young people do work at McDonald's in the minimum wage jobs, uh,
a significant and majority of the workers, [inaudible] kids, they are often,
and I'd met them at McDonald's, uh, they all workers, uh,
who have children themselves. Uh, when we,
we work very hard to raise the minimum wage at Amazon, uh,
and at Disney we put pressure on both of those companies and they did the right
thing. And when you talk to the people that Amazon who got that raise,
these are not kids. These are people in their thirties. These, uh,
these are ordinary adults who cannot make it on 12 or 13 bucks. And I was, so,
I think the argument that all their old kids, uh,
is not really quite accurate. Well, not even that all they're, they're all kids,
but that if they are kids,
what would you think about making a minimum wage for someone who is under 18?
That's different from a minimum wage of someone who's a legal adult? I'm not,
I'm not for that. Uh, I think we do it and,
and look at many of these young people have their own needs.
I just talked to a young woman, um, uh, last night, uh,
who was working, going to college, working full time,
trying to take care of her family as well. So I think, look,
the minimum wage has not been raised in 10 years.
It is now $7 and 25 cents an hour, which is clearly unacceptable. Um,
cost of housing, California, all of this country is rising fairly rapidly.
People can't afford health care. [inaudible] can't afford college.
I don't think it's asking our employers too much to pay at least $15 an hour
minimum wage.
No, I'm glad you brought up Amazon. This is one of the,
one of the things that always freaks me out is when I find out that enormous
corporations that make billions of dollars have tax loopholes where they
literally pay no money. How is that possible and how do you stop that?
Well, it's the same thing as the drug companies.
How is it possible that we pay 10 times more for insulin in this country?
[inaudible] and for other drugs than the one in Canada or countries around the
world. And the answer is it's power.
So what is, what is the goal of major corporations in America?
It's the be deregulated as much as possible.
So in some cases they can pollute our water, our air, our environment.
It's also not the panty taxes. [inaudible] Trump campaign, as we recall,
he said, my tax plan is not going to benefit the wealthy.
It's going to benefit working people while turns out over 10 years,
83% of the benefit at the end of 10 years goes to the top 1%.
That's what these guys though I remember on the call,
the ranking member on the budget committee in the Senate and some guy came
forward representing, I don't know, one of the big business organizations.
Uh, and this is their agenda. Their agenda was to cut social security,
Medicare and Medicaid and to do away with old corporate taxes.
So what you have right now, that's, that's what greed is about.
They wanted wall. So as you indicated,
you have a company like Amazon owned by Jeff Bezos who happens to be the
wealthiest guy in America, worth about 150 billion.
Amazon paid zero in federal income taxes, and it's not just him.
Dozens of corporations paid nothing or very, very little.
And on top of all of that,
you got these guys able to stashed all over the world,
trillions of dollars, trillions of dollars in the Cayman Islands,
in Bermuda, in Luxenberg, and of the tax savings. That is insane.
And that has got to end [inaudible]
yet. How is it legal to do that? Why is it legal,
Joe? It is legal because they make the laws, right? All right.
You know it. That is what he,
you're touching now on the heart and soul of the tragedy of American politics.
How does it happen that on issue after issue, the American people,
the working class of this country wants something.
Nobody pays any attention to it.
But billionaires want something and it gets done.
And that has to do with a corrupt political system. So right now,
if you are a the Koch brothers or some multi-billionaire,
you say to the leadership of the Republican body in some cases to the democratic
money, Hey, guess what?
We're prepared to put hundreds of millions of dollars in the UK,
made hundreds of millions of dollars coming from one or two people.
And here is my agenda. I want tax breaks, I wanna trade system,
which will enable me to shut down in this country and go to China or Mexico and
pay people there. Two bucks an hour.
I want to be able to do more pollution cause on a, I don't like all of this,
you know, money I have to spend preventing uh,
pollution of the air or the water. That's what I want you to do. And by the way,
I'm worried about the deficit. So you may as well cut social security,
Medicare and Medicaid.
How many Americans actually believe that we should give tax breaks to
billionaires and cut social security, Medicare and Medicaid.
Very few that is PR.
Talked to Mitch McConnell get mature on the show is that is exactly what he
believes.
But that's ridiculous. Right?
And it seems that if you just took away those tax breaks,
the enormous amount of money that would come from those corporations having to
pay their fair share would take care of lot of the expenses of all these things
that you're proposing. Exactly. How like, okay,
let's talk about the education because the idea of free education is a wonderful
thing for people. Um,
I mean the idea that you get out of college and you're in debt in,
in an insane amount that you might have 10 20 years where you have to pay it
back. And, and I know many people
[inaudible] people who are getting their social security checks garnished right
now. It's not 10 to 20 years. In some cases it's a literally a lifetime.
Now, a lot of that is mean.
It's got to in some way be preventable by what we're talking about here.
Absolutely. Right. Is that how you would pay for it?
I'll tell you exactly how it would pay for it.
And we pay for every idea that we have. We pay for it and we pay for it.
By understanding that today we have massive levels of income and wealth
inequality and we have in many cases the wealthy and large corporations paying
nothing or very little in taxes. Here is the issue in terms of education.
40 50 years ago, you are an average American working class person.
You graduated high school, especially if there was a union around.
You can go out and get a job and make it into the middle class.
You could own your own home, you could send your kids to school.
You lived a pretty good life. I made it in the middle class
40 or 50 years later, there's an explosion of technology.
There's a growth in unfettered free trade and it is clear now that most people
to make it into the middle class are going to need a higher education that's
college or maybe it's technical training in order to become a skilled worker.
It is insane to me to deny working class people in lower income people.
The opportunity to get that education because the cost of college has sought.
So all that I say is that a hundred plus years ago,
the American people said that we should have free public education.
I went to a public school, my parents didn't pay a nickel, went to kindergarten,
I went through the 12th grade. Pretty good education in Brooklyn, New York.
All that I'm saying is the world has changed and high school degree is not good
enough anymore. So expand that concept through college. Now.
Guess what, 50 years ago, do you know how much the University of California,
very great university costs in terms of tuition, how much? Virtually free.
What's it now? I Dunno, but it's pretty high. It is hard.
It's thousands and thousands of nos.
So you had great universities like the University of California, uh, city,
University of New York state colleges,
all of this country where tuition was virtually free.
And then what happened for a variety of political reasons,
states and the federal government started cutting back on higher education and
put more and more burden on the student with higher and higher tuition,
which is where we are today.
So all that I'm saying is in the year 2019 2020 if our working class kids are
going to go out and get the jobs that are out there, they need a,
they need a higher education,
which should be tuition free in terms of the cancellation of debt,
which is my view. You got 45 million people, um,
who are dealing with that. I'll never forget this.
This is where I really hit me. I was in Burlington,
Vermont and I had a meeting on an issue and a young woman comes up and she says,
she's a doctor. She graduated in medical school. She's very happy.
She's practicing community health center, loves what she's doing. He said,
Bernie, I gotta tell you though, I am $300,000 in debt.
Having gone to medical school, I couldn't believe it. I was in Iowa.
A young woman, $400,000 in debt.
This is not unusual for medical schools and dental schools and you know,
ordinary people,
50,000 a hundred thousand dollars we're going to college or are getting a
master's degree. We promise these young people, he said, go to college,
go on and get an education. You'll get decent paying jobs. Well,
the answer is they have not been able to do that.
So what we have proposed in one piece of legislation or to actually is to make
public colleges and universities tuition free,
cancel all student debt in this country that will cost two point $2 trillion,
a lot of money over a 10 year period.
We do this through a tax on Wall Street speculation,
which will bring in two point $4 trillion.
We bailed out Wall Street 11 years ago, and by the way,
these are crooks on Wall Street who engaged in illegal behavior.
Taxpayers against my boat, bailed them out. If we can bail out Wall Street,
you know what?
We can cancel student debt and provide public colleges and universities tuition
free. When you say a tax on Wall Street speculation. W What exactly?
To me it will be a tax on a all of the trends,
every sale of attacks people buy and sell stocks and bonds,
all of them.
We have a very modest tax on it and by the way it will have an impact on
speculation by cutting back on the high frequency trading, which we don't see.
So you would just, there is, there's no current tax on direct,
so you would put a small amount and that would do the job.
That would [inaudible]
would raise more than enough money. It's a very small tax. It exists a small,
how much? It depends on the nature of the transaction,
but it's less than one half of 1% really? Yeah. [inaudible] yeah,
because the amount of stocks being so broad and so, and this is an under, again,
a new idea. It's being done in countries all over the world.
What about the here,
here's one of the darkest things about student loans is that if,
if you go bankrupt it doesn't matter, you still owe that and that.
That's kind of crazy. I mean, if you have like a serious medical issue,
if you're, you're held up, whatever, whatever happens to you, that's awful.
You go bankrupt. Most of those things are resolved, but not student loans.
Right.
All right. I mean, again,
this talks to the [inaudible] and that has to do with bankruptcy law,
which was passed against my vote. Uh, and while you were on bankruptcy,
and actually I should've mentioned this before,
when you talk about the healthcare system,
a half a million Americans every single year go bankrupt because of medical
bills that they can't pay. But you're right, with students.
I talked to this guy in Nevada, never will forget it guys. It's Bernie.
You know, I'm all, when my, it guy's in his fifties and he said, you know, I,
I've been paying off my student debt for years.
I'm going nowhere because the interest rates are high and I fear very much,
which is the case that they will start garnishing taking away my social security
checks, taking money away from me. So people are carrying this burden.
The result is that they can't, in many cases,
get married and have kids. They certainly can't buy a home.
They can't buy a car. They are really crushed by this debt.
And what was the crime? What did they do? They tried to get a higher education.
I think that's pretty crazy.
And a lot of them, when they do this higher education, they're 18 years old.
Imagine making a decision when your brain isn't even fully formed.
That's gonna Affect you for the rest of your life. You've got it. Exactly right.
And you talk to these kids. So how much debt do you owe? Um,
what kind of interest rates your bank? Gee, I really don't know.
They just told me to sign over here. So right now,
right now we are a week, not even a week out,
just a few days away from two mass shootings in a row.
And whenever these things happen,
there's all these people that want action,
but nobody knows exactly what to do. There's calls for gun control,
there's calls for mental health reform, there's calls for, I mean,
what if anything can be done to stop these things from happening?
And how have you sat down and tried to come up with some sort of a solution and
is there a solution?
Look, I would be lying to you if I told you I had a magical answer.
I don't, and this is such a horrific situation. I, you know,
we were in, um, you know, we, we had a town meeting,
we were in Nevada actually in Las Vegas when El Paso happened.
And, uh, we did a town, me and I said, okay,
let's take a moment of silence to remember the victims and pray for the
survivors. Literally the next day and another part of Las Vegas.
I have to do it again. And I said,
I can't believe that just yesterday we did this and I have to do it again.
This is, I, I don't know what the words, you know,
my friend Bedo or rock would say good. You don't know what words, what,
what can you say? It happens again and again,
who can imagine some lunatic walking into a school or a mall or just on a
nightclub area and taken out an assault weapon and shooting down people.
And that we almost become,
to accept this as a normal part of American life is, is incredible. Is,
is, is, is just totally demoralizing art. So here's what I think.
There's no magical answer and, but let me tell you what I think. First of all,
this is the reality. The reality is that today as we speak,
there are approximately 400 million guns in America today.
We have more guns than we have people.
We have between five to 10 million assault weapons.
And an assault weapon, as you know,
is a military style weapon designed to kill human beings kind of rapidly.
So that's, and then on top of that we have, again,
nothing to be proud of, but you know,
we have a number of mentally unstable people, people for whatever reason,
or walk in the streets. This suicidal, homicidal. That's the mix that we have.
I think the answer is, and I'm not the guide who invent all these ideas,
but here's some of what we have to do. First of all,
if you want own a gun in America,
you have got to do, we have got to know that you are a stable person.
And that means that we need to expand, uh,
a the background checks that currently exist. Okay?
So we've got to know, did you beat up your wife, have you committed crimes, uh,
et Cetera, et cetera. What is the state of your mental health? Uh, number two,
we gotta make that universal.
Number two right now that there is a background check.
If you walk into a gun, show it to look into a gun shop,
but you can buy guns in various states at a gun show and you don't have to do
any of that as are you. And I got to a country, you sell me a gun,
I don't have to. And you know, I don't have to do it. Third of all,
I can today legally walk into a gun show, uh,
pass the background check and buy a dozen guns.
Walk out and sell them to criminal elements who will use them for bad things.
So I think those are issues, um,
that most Americans believe we have got to deal with. And we can.
Fourthly, I happen to believe, and I believe this for 30 years,
that we should not be selling or distributing assault weapons in this country.
They are weapons of mass destruction in a sense.
They killed people rapidly as we saw in. And thank God by the way,
when we talk about both Dayton and El Paso, thank God cops were there very,
very quickly and did an incredible job for.
So that guy had walked into the nightclub,
there could have been dozens and dozens more people killed in it within a few
minutes time. Um, I happen to believe a,
that we should not be selling or distributing assault weapons in this country.
That's my deal, period. Uh,
so I believe in a ban on assault weapons and I think we have got to begin
thinking about when we have five to 10 million assault weapons,
which is more than the u s military has.
We have to think about a strong licensing procedure in terms of who owns these
assault women. So that's some of what I think there are many other things,
but those are some of the ideas that are out there
now.
The legal gun owners who are law abiding citizens who would never in a million
years think about going around shooting people, but they love guns.
They hear this kind of stuff about like banning assault rifles,
banning assault weapons. They don't even like the term assault weapons, right?
They like to refer to them as their individual names for whatever they are.
These people feel like this is an inexorable part of being an American,
that you should be able to own a gun. It's written into our bill of rights.
It's written into our, the way we way this country was founded,
it's the second amendment. What do you say to those people that don't,
that don't want to give up their guns but they wouldn't do and they want to
protect themselves.
They feel like these guns are viable options to protect themselves from
criminal.
I understand that. And Joe, you may know him,
a senator from the state of Vermont and the state of Vermont is one of the most
rural states in America.
Every fall we had a whole thousands and thousands of people are out in the woods
hunting. And it's something that's part of our tradition. I believe in it.
I believe in the second amendment, but all that I ask of the governance,
and you're absolutely right, 99.9% of gun owners would never in a million,
billion years think of doing these horrible things.
But in the moment that we are living in, uh,
I think that we're all going to have to make some concessions to the reality of
what is going on. And that is that there is a small number of,
call them what you want to pray for people who are prepared to do that.
You know, in Australia, you remember that terrible. A New Zealand, I'm sorry,
the terrible shooting at the mosque and they moved pretty quickly, uh,
in an aggressive way. So, you know, I wish I can say in, in,
in the best of all possible worlds. Yeah. You know,
you could own any weapon you want and so forth. And son,
we're not living in the best of all possible worlds.
We're living in a world where
we're shocked every day by our own. So I agree.
We are living in a terrible situation. I mean,
there's hundreds of mass shootings a year now, which is insane.
And if you look at the number in comparison to the rest of the world,
it's crazy. Like a big one in another country,
like three mass shootings in a year. We had more than 270. It's,
it's crazy. But how would you implement something like this?
Well,
the idea of banning assault weapons has been done in 1994.
We've manned assault weapons. Uh, I believe, I believe it was for 10 years. Uh,
that ban was undone by Republican majority. Uh,
and it didn't, you know, I'm not suggesting,
by the way that anything here that the few banned assault weapons tomorrow,
that would radically change everything.
But we have got to do the best that we can do. And again,
I preface my remarks by telling you I don't have a magical solution.
You've got hundreds of millions of guns out there.
You have people who should not be owning these guns, who gets set off by God,
knows what and and do terrible things.
All we can do is the best that we could do.
But to say we can't do anything I think is a real disservice to the American.
And I'll tell you something else that bothers me. You know,
in addition to the horror of seeing people lying on the street dead is what this
is doing to the children of this country. And I think we underestimate that.
I have seven grandchildren and and for them and for kids,
all of this country, you're going to see the falls coming.
Kids coming back to school, you're going to see in schools all over America,
drills, art. This is what you do if somebody walks into the school, all right,
you're going to hide under here. You go over there. Kids I,
a couple of months ago, I was in Iowa, this guy, he's about six foot,
two big guy, probably a football player. And he says, Senator Sanders,
I gotta tell you that the young people in my school are increasingly frightened,
terrified about what could happen in the school. Think about what this,
the trauma, the trauma of,
of what this gun violence is doing. So I think we're all as Americans,
they ain't no easy answers here,
but they were all going to have to come together and figured this one out and do
the best that weekend.
Now would that mean forcibly removing these guns from people's homes?
You gotta have the FBI knocking on somebody's doors and taking them.
That's not what we do in America.
You have 400 million guns already out there building more every year.
Right now as we speak,
gun manufacturers or make money manufacturers are making more guns.
This is happening right now. So if those guns already exist,
there's more than enough. Oh yeah. How would you stop?
Well, again, I think, look, you know,
I do think there should be a ban on assault weapons.
So that means that manufacturers would not be able to produce or sell those
weapons per year
to American citizens, but not to the military obviously. Right?
Obviously. Yeah. Okay. So you know,
and your point is well taken if you've got 4 million guns out there, you know,
so I, I think there are approaches, no one has any magical solution,
but I'd given you a,
I'll tell you something else that I didn't mention and that is the role of gun
manufacturers is that if you are a gun manufacturer and you are selling a hell
of a lot of guns to a gun store in an area,
which normally you would not think, I mean these guys know,
you know what cities by what towns, by comedy guns.
And if suddenly there is a tremendous demand,
you've got to be thinking and be why is,
why is this gun store buying so many guns?
It doesn't reflect the population in the area.
You've gotta deal with that issue with a gun owner's going to have to take some
responsibility besides the guns. The gun manufacturers, I'm sure. Right?
The, besides the guns, the gun manufacturers,
the other gigantic issue is mental health.
The only way any of this ever happens is someone has to be insanely mentally
depraved. This the only way,
and many of them are Medicaid and many of them are on pharmaceutical drugs and
they have been since they were children,
including amphetamines like Adderall and Prozac and all this different stuff
that has varied effects on the human brain.
What could be done? What would you done to analyze this?
To find out what the cause and effect are and to try to figure out what role,
what role and how much these drugs are responsible.
Okay, well two things. Let me response respond first by saying,
it goes without saying that we have a mental health crisis in America before we
even talk about jokes and for whatever reason, um,
you know,
there are a whole lot of people in the nature of our healthcare system.
Getting back to healthcare is, I just talked to a woman literally last night,
um, and we had a town meeting and she said,
this is unbelievable. She said, Bernie,
I was in Las Vegas when the terrible shooting took place. Okay,
and now I am, and I can understand this perfectly.
I'm seeing Dayton and I'm seeing watching television,
El Paso and I'm getting a p t p s PTSD reaction. All right,
that's totally under.
If you were in a place where people were shut down and actually I'm trying to
get counseling, I can't find it. I remember a guy called up,
a woman called at my office in Burlington, Vermont and she said,
I'm worried about my husband, what he, my brother was his brother,
what he might do to himself with somebody else.
We're looking for mental health counseling.
We can't find something that we can afford.
So we need above and beyond gun violence.
We need an, it's why I believe in Medicare for all mental health is healthcare.
You break your arm, that's a health issue. That's a medical issue.
Mental health is a medical issue and we have got to make mental health
counseling available. All people in this country when they need it,
not six months from now at a price they can afford and under Medicare for all
would be free. So that's number one. Number two, your point about, uh,
studying the impact of drugs on people's behavior and possibly resulting in
violence absolutely deserves to be studied.
We should be studying the impact of drugs. In my view, this is a layman's view.
You know, I'm not a psychiatrist.
I worry very much that we are over medicating kids in schools.
You know, we have this uh, deficit, the deficient issue. You know,
kids are running around in their act of, you know, when I was a kid,
people used the runaround Labor Act. If you know what they wasn't,
they weren't drugged up. So I worry about that whole business.
But your point is well taken.
I think we need to study this issue and make sure that these drugs in fact are
not causing kinds of reactions that we will regret later.
No. On the subject of drugs,
marijuana is obviously a big issue in this country and we've seen many states
make it recreational, including this one.
What do you think could be done and what should be done to have this across the
board, especially federally? You know,
there's a guy that I have on the podcast coming up soon. His name's John Norris,
and he wrote a book on the cartels growing marijuana illegally all over this
country and selling it,
especially particularly in California now because it's a misdemeanor because
it's legal recreationally and selling it with all sorts of horrible pesticides
on it. All sorts of like very, in fact, deadly chemicals.
All of this, because it's not federally legal,
because we can have sanctioned licensed companies doing an ethical job of
growing something than any responsible law abiding person should be able to
consume.
Okay. Um, let me say this.
When I ran for president for the Democratic nomination in 2016 I talked about a
broken criminal justice system,
which ends up having in the United States more people in jail than any other
country. We have more people in jail than China does,
which is a communist authoritarian country.
And what I called for then and I call for now is the legalization of marijuana
in America right now, you have a federal law.
It's called the controlled substance act. He has heroin. Here is marijuana.
They're at the same level. That is insane. Heroin is a killer drug.
You can argue the pluses and minuses of marijuana, but marijuana ain't heroin,
so we have to end that and that's what I will do.
This president of the United States,
I believe we can do that through executive order and I will do that.
Second of all, what we have now is number of states, and I'm very proud.
I talked about during 2016 what seemed kind of radical,
the need to legalize the decriminalized marijuana,
a very radical idea four years ago.
It is spreading all over the country and pied the way it blows my mind to drive
through Nevada. Think here even in California, you'll see signs.
Corporations buy our marijuana. Yeah. If four years ago people getting arrested,
you're doing that, right? Their lives being destroyed. Oh,
particularly in Nevada. There was life sentences given out in the 70s.
Can you believe that?
And now you have corporation selling the damn product that people went to jail
for. Um, so I think ultimately in a,
we've got to legalize marijuana.
And what's good news in a sense is some communities,
some cities are expunging the records. So if you were arrested, uh,
have a criminal record for selling marijuana, that is being expunction,
that is the right thing to do. You know,
we can argue about the pluses and minuses. I'm not a great fan of, of drugs.
Other people, you know, I smoked marijuana a couple of times.
Didn't do much for me.
Other people I guess have different interests a couple of times.
That's certainly true. It didn't do much for you. Yeah. Maybe Craig getting it.
I was in Vermont, northern Vermont. That's the problem.
Maybe I'll do something for you. Well, make me cough a whole lot. All right.
But I got the other people have had different experiences for sure. Yeah,
I'm certainly have. Um,
well the other problem is of course with illegal drugs comes you get this
horrible cycle,
particularly in inner cities where you have people that are incarcerated for
illegal drugs, illegal drugs seem to be the only way out.
The hard drugs when we're talking about cocaine and all these other drugs,
how does one stop that?
And would you ever consider legalizing all drugs or decriminalizing all drugs?
No, I wouldn't. Uh, but you're touching on a real tragedy. Yes.
And when we talk about criminal justice in America,
we have over 2 million people in jail.
They are disproportionately African American, Latino, and native American.
And here's what I think. I think in the wealthiest country,
in the history of the world, what we have got to do,
instead of building more jails and locking up more people,
we really do have to invest in our young people,
especially young people in distressed communities. What does that mean?
If we can, and we can do this with a proper amount of resources,
make sure the kids are not dropping out of school.
If you drop out of school today, you know,
say you drop out in u s second or third year of high school,
you don't have an education, you don't have any job skills.
What are you gonna do with your life? And the answer is you may well do drugs,
you know, or you'll get in trouble. Self destructive activity,
destructive activity, you gonna end up in jail.
It makes so much more sense from a humane perspective,
protecting our people as well as the financial situation.
We spend that $80 billion yet to invest in these kids. What does it mean?
It means making sure that they get the education that they need.
Paying attention, having good schools,
making sure that they get the jobs that are out there doing job training.
There was a principal in a school in southern Vermont,
I'll never forget what she said. It was a working class school. And she said,
Bernie, I love these kids. I am not gonna let them drop out.
And she had a mentoring program just watching the kids who were mostly at risk
so that they would not end up, uh,
going through the cracks and getting into trouble.
That's what we should be doing as a nation. And when we do that,
we invest in the kids, we get them jobs, we're going to education.
The likelihood is the likelihood of them falling into bad ways is significantly
reduced.
The, all those things sound great.
The uncomfortable reality about drugs though is that when drugs are illegal,
criminal seldom,
and there's obviously a need for drugs in terms of not necessarily a need,
but a demand for drugs is a demand for trucks in this country that's absolutely
fueling Mexican cartels and illegal drug runners inside this country.
I mean there's, there's a lot of that. How do you, how do you curb that?
If drugs are illegal, boy,
you're raising a deep question. Yes. All right. So the question is send
truly that you're asking is what is the cause of the opioid epidemic?
Yes.
That's one. That's one aspect of it. But,
but the opioid epidemic is interesting because there's so much of it that's
coming legally. Right? That's not the drug cartels.
That's the pharmaceutical industry. Right. But the heroin is illegal. Yes.
Right. Alright.
Now you're asking, this is a very, very deep question,
which we don't talk about terribly much.
Why is it that so many of our people are turning to drugs to alcohol,
by the way, and I don't mean a drink a night,
but I mean serious alcohol problems and tragically to suicide,
we now have for the last three years,
something that is a historical never happened before in modern history.
And that is our life expectancies actually going down.
And this is hitting all over the country,
but it is especially hitting rural areas.
And what the doctors are saying is that these are diseases of despair,
despair. So you're in West Virginia,
here in rural Ohio or any place for month, any place.
And the job you used to have earning a decent living is now in China.
Your kid can't afford to go to college. Maybe you can't afford healthcare.
You've got nothing to look forward to under that scenario.
Drugs become alcohol becomes a way out.
And that the worst case scenario is suicide.
So I think what we're talking about is why is this happening as often in rural
areas and urban as well? And how can we,
how can we reestablish hope and optimism in the American people?
And that gets back to a whole lot of other issues. It means if people have,
healthcare is a right, that will certainly play a role in this thing.
They walk into the doctor when they need,
but it also means that people need decent jobs that pay them a living wage.
That means we have to rebuild rural America.
We have to rebuild a depress communities in urban America.
It means that we have to have a great educational system and people say,
oh, that's great Bernie. That's utopian. It is not utopian.
This is something that in the wealthiest country, in the history of the world,
we can afford and we should be doing rather than giving, uh,
creating a situation where Amazon pay zero in federal income taxes.
So to answer your question, there's a deep question and again,
I'm not here to tell Ya, I have all the answers,
but there are a lot of people out there who have basically given up hope.
And for those people, I guess drugs is the alternative.
So what you're saying essentially is that if we can do something to mitigate
despair,
then we'll do something to at least stop some of the demand for these,
these elite,
I believe that is the case. Look, if I am optimistic,
if I'm excited about going to work tomorrow and I'm seeing my kid doing great in
school, and you know,
when I get sick I can go to the doctor's office that have a sense of community.
My downtown is not all bordered up because businesses have left. But we have a,
we have a community. Yeah. The light,
the strong likelihood is there will be less diseases of despair and drugs, uh,
than we currently see.
Now when we're talking about impoverished communities and chronically when,
when you're talking about cities like Baltimore or parts of Chicago and Detroit
that have just been in a terrible state of despair for long periods of time,
and it doesn't seem like there's a way out that people that are born there,
the people that live there, they live in this state of, of despair.
What,
what can be done to resolve all of these terribly impoverished communities and
bring them up to a standard where these kids that grow up there,
that they feel like there is an out, that they do have an opportunity.
And why is this not addressed when we talk about making America great?
Wouldn't like fixing the worst parts of the country, be the primary concern.
The,
the less people that grow up in a terribly disadvantaging position from birth
would not be an important thing. And what can you do to resolve that?
Well, Joel, I think you, you know, you said it better than I can.
I think you're right. You know,
when we talk about what it means to live in a great society,
a great nation and nation that we're proud of,
I'm afraid there are some people who have incredible wealth and powers.
So you know what's great is that we're seeing a growth in the number of
billionaires in America. Isn't that terrific?
And we've got one guy who was worth $155 billion. How great. Oh, by the way,
we're building one nuclear weapons and we're spending $750 billion a year on the
military. Isn't that extraordinary? And by the way,
you see the yacht that that billionaire has, you know, it's three miles long.
Isn't that great? Your point is that we have to,
I think as I understand what you're saying,
we have to redefine what being a great nation is about.
We are not a great nation when we have 40 million people living in poverty and
in despair. We're not a great nation.
We have massive levels of income and wealth inequality.
When 87 million people can afford to go to a doctor today.
So Dancy your question.
I think that as a nation we have got to focus a great deal of attention on those
distressed communities. Often they're African American, often they're Latino,
often they are rural white communities.
And that means making sure that the kids,
they get the quality education that they deserve.
Making sure that we're creating good paying jobs in those communities.
I voted against NAFTA,
permanent normal trade relations with China and other trade agreements because I
knew that those agreements were written by corporate America with the goal of
shutting down plants in this country and moving abroad.
And the result of that has been the loss of millions of good paying jobs and the
thick,
complete destruction of communities all across this country in the south and all
across this country. So we have got to rebuild those communities.
We have got to bring high tech jobs, not just to silicon valley, uh,
but to rural America. Again, I don't have magical answers,
but the goal is we will not under a Sanders administration,
turn our backs on distressed communities. We will rebuild those committees.
We will build the millions of units of affordable housing that we need. Now.
Think about what it means to a community now where people are living in terrible
housing or housing they cannot afford.
When we put young people to work rebuilding their own communities,
will that become a an indication of hope and optimism? I think it will.
We're talking about so many deeply important issues and all them that will be
under the control or at least to the direction of the one person who winds up
becoming the president of United States. Is it an impossible job?
I mean it seems like being the president,
you are managing so many different aspects of our economy,
our culture, our safety, our environment,
international communication, and it's so,
it's so in depth. How does one person do a job like,
well,
one person doesn't do it and you certainly don't do it by tweeting every other
day. Major policy issues. I think he tweets a lot more than every other.
You know what you do, and this is the way any sane president operates,
is you need to be working with the smartest men and women from all walks of life
who understand these issues. Every issue we have touched on,
Joe is enormously complicated. And I can send out a, you know,
20 word tweet on it, but that doesn't solve it. So unlike Trump, you know,
we will bring together, uh,
the best and most knowledgeable people in this country to address the housing
crisis to address the issue of, of these diseases of despair.
We didn't even touch on climate change, uh, you know,
and then the future of the planet.
How do we lead the world and transforming our energy system and creating the
kind of jobs that we need?
How do we revitalize American democracy so that instead of suppressing the vote,
we're getting more young people involved in the political process.
So to answer your question,
it is not a one person job and anyone that thinks it is, is that wrong.
You need the help of a very strong administration that knows the issues that
comes from the ranks of the working class. And this is the promise I will make.
Heart-Mind administration, unlike Trump's,
is not going to be filled with billionaires whose, you know,
basically a very often greedy type people who it is going to be filled with the
best people, often from the working class itself, from the trade union movement,
people who are gonna help us create policies that work for workers and not just
the, the billionaire class.
Now we're getting to the end of your hour here.
So climate change is obviously an enormous issue for our country and for the
world. What,
what could be done and what do you think you can do as president that can
somehow or another slow down this, this process?
Well, first of all, we have to have a president who, unlike Trump, uh,
beliefs in science than I do.
And what the scientists are telling us, as I mentioned earlier,
is that we have fewer than 12 years to transform our energy system or else there
will be irreparable damage done to our country. But to the world now,
climate change is not just an American issue. So we could do tomorrow,
do all the right things,
but if China and Russia and India and the rest of the Brazil and Africa does not
do the right thing, you know, we're not going to make the progress we need.
So here is what we have to do in my view. Number one,
we have to tell the fossil fuel industry that they are short term profits and
they make a whole lot of money.
They're short term profits are not more important than the future of this
planet. I don't think that's a hard sell to make.
You cannot keep producing a product which is destroying the planet in the United
States and around the world.
So by saying that, you're saying you would have to move a,
we would have to move consciously away absent fossil fuels. No.
If so Butson maybe if we do that, how do you tell the fossil fuel companies,
do you tell them you can't sell fossil fuels anymore?
There are a variety of ways to do that, but that is the, the
bottom line. And, and by the way, in the midst of that,
we do what we call is a, um,
a just transition.
The guy out on the oil rig today simply wants to feed his family and the coal
miners today want to feed their families and we're not gonna leave them.
I'm a pro worker.
I have the probably the strongest bro Worker record of any member of the
congress.
So that is not my intention to throw these guys out on the and women out on the
street and ignore the pain that they will go through.
We are proposing billions of dollars to rebuild those communities and make sure
that those guys and women get new jobs.
So we're not just discarding people in the fossil fuel industry,
but ultimately the product that they are producing,
which is now carbon emissions, is destroying the planet.
So we have to move away from fossil fuels in a very bold way into energy
efficiency. Right now in my own state of Vermont and all over this country,
there are buildings which are incredibly wasteful.
We don't have the windows, we don't know the installation.
We don't have the roofing,
the doors that we need to keep the buildings warm in the winter and cool in the
summer and we can create just a, an incredible number of jobs,
just retrofitting of buildings. Second of all, uh,
we need to move very aggressively, uh,
to sustainable energies like wind and solar in California.
You doing a good job with wind. I was doing good job, Texas doing a good job.
We've got to do much more solar.
There is incredible potential out there at prices.
Solar has dropped in recent years and we have got to not only transform the
energy system and our own country,
we got to lead the world in working with Russia and China because in this issue
we are in it together. And here's my dream and baby,
this may be a utopian dream.
The world right now is spending a trillion and a half dollars on weapons of
destruction designed to kill each other.
And maybe just maybe if we had a kind of elite,
and I hope to be that leader who says to the world,
instead of spending a trillion and a half dollars killing each other,
maybe we use those resources to transform the global energy system and save the
planet for our kids and our grandchildren. That's the goal that I have.
Well, these, these ideas sound great,
but in the competitive environment of global politics,
how would you convince Russia or China or any of these countries to do something
that would put them in some sort of a competitive disadvantage?
Well, and the answer is, Joe,
if we do not do that in 50 a hundred years,
everybody's going to be terrible dissident. And look, I'm not, you know,
I'm saying that, I'm not telling you that tomorrow what's going to happen,
but you got to make the case. These people, you know, Putin is a dictator.
I disliked him intensely. You know, Ci in China, very authoritarian self on top,
but they're not crazy people.
And presumably they have concerned about their kids and their grandchildren.
This is a planet under siege. You know,
I don't want to become a science fiction.
You've all seen the movies in the media racing toward earth.
We got blow up the earth. What do we do? Well, we gotta get together.
This is in a sense what that is about it you don't want to think about in 1941,
uh, after Pearl Harbor, all right,
we were faced with a war in the east with China, a war in the west,
in Europe with Hitler. Within two years,
the United States had transformed its economy to address.
And when the war basically in two or three years by re industrializing comer,
we can do it. We can lead the world. That's what we have to do.
So in your eyes,
we have to look at the economy almost as if the same kind of threat,
or excuse me, the environment has, if it's the same kind of threat,
is Nazi German and act together.
Look, if you asked the Defense Department, you asked the CIA,
you asked the defense people all over the world,
tell us what the great national security threat is. You know what it is?
It is climate change.
There's a lot of people though that are of this, how would you convince them?
I mean, this is a big part of the problem, right? There's,
there's a narrative that you hear from a lot of people that, oh, you know,
climate change is not approved, proven science and climate change is a hoax.
And I mean, this is something that's repeated over and over again. And um,
I'm sure some of it has to do with lobbyists and some of it has to do with the
merchants of doubt that go out there and see the world with disinformation to
try to increase their profits and continue the practices that they're currently
enjoying.
You know,
Joe and I'm thinking back and I don't know if all of you listeners can remember
this cause molder the most,
but I can remember tobacco and cigarette ads on television moment. Yes,
Dr. Guy Dressed in a white frock smoking away. This is a great cigarette.
It'll improve your health. They lied.
The tobacco industry knew exactly what was going on.
And the fossil fuel industry is lying right now.
And the president of the United States is either too stupid to understand what
the scientists are telling us or he is lying as well. Climate should look,
I am not the scientists. This is not my idea. I listen to the scientists.
The debate is long over climate change is real. My God,
look at what's happening around the world. Say the worst. You know,
July was I think the warmest July or warmest month in the modern history of the
world. Uh, the, the audit ice is melting, uh,
heat waves in Europe. All right? Just look out the window at what's going on.
Uh, so this is not Bernie Sanders talking. This is the scientific community.
Climate change is real.
It will only get worse if we do not act boldly to cut carbon emissions.
Well we just did an hour, sir.
So I'm gonna let you go cause I know you've got very important things to do.
One last question.
If you got into the office and you found out something about aliens,
if you found out something about UFO, would you let us know?
Well, I'll tell you,
my wife would demand that I let you know as your wife a UFO nut. Now,
she's not a UFO nut, which is Burdick. What is going on?
Do you have any access to records and you don't have any access? I don't,
honestly. I don't know. Okay. You let us know though. All right.
I'll be [inaudible] the show. How's it? Alright, thank you, sir.
I appreciate your time. So thank you very much.
[inaudible].